- Growing up, I loved
reading the Guinness Book
of World Records.
And over the years,
they verified some
incredible physical feats,
which I'm about to react to.
Huge thanks to Dropbox
for sponsoring this video.
Stay tuned to learn how
you can get a free trial
of Dropbox Professional.
Peewoop!
(knuckles cracking)
Most knuckles cracked in 30 seconds.
I feel like this
is my morning routine
right here. (chuckles)
Caught on camera, Dr.
Mike's morning routine.
I feel like I could beat this one.
(joints cracking)
Oh, cramp in the hamstring!
Cramp in the hamstring!
(screen beeps)
(light music)
(man whistles)
(woman sings low note)
Vocal chords are obviously
what give you the ability
to speak and produce sound.
The larynx is a muscle.
By being able to control that muscle,
whether you're stretching
it out, you shortening it,
you actually change your
ability to control your pitch.
And just like any other muscle,
this muscle can be trained.
That's why we have vocal coaches.
- [Sam] See how low you can get.
(Dr. Mike inhales)
- Was that low?
- [Sam] I heard nothing.
(both laugh)
It was totally silent.
- Exactly, it was that low.
(Dr. Mike sings low note)
(both laugh)
(screen beeps)
What do we got here?
Is this an age-related one?
Wow. 116 as of March.
Is this person still live, Sam?
- [Sam] Yes, she is still alive.
- Wow. So two years older,
three years older, basically.
Oh, birthday's coming up.
So gonna be a solid 119 in a few days.
Happy early birthday, Kane Tanaka.
(serene piano music)
(people clapping)
Do you think she knows?
(woman speaking japanese)
Yep. There you go.
She goes, "I don't know what this is."
- My name is Nicholas James Stoeberl,
and I have the longest
tongue in recorded history.
- Wow.
- I think one of the most useful things
that my tongue offers
is actually not having
to use a napkin.
- Must be popular with his partners.
- I use my tongue, actually,
to create, you could call it, art.
I sort of like to paint
on canvas using acrylic.
- Everyone's got their thing.
He paints with his
tongue that's very long.
That's the longest tongue in the world.
I'm sure other people
would be doing other things
with that tongue, but maybe it wasn't safe
for Guinness World Records
to investigate further.
(screen beeps)
(man groans)
What? The longest time in
an abdominal plank position.
Okay, here, we're talking
isometric contraction.
We're literally not shortening,
not lengthening the fibers,
but keeping them tight and
engaged the entire time.
- [Sam] Before you keep watching,
what's your prediction
for the longest plank?
- I'm gonna say something
wild. Five hours.
In February, 2020, George Hood planked
for an astonishing 8 hours 15 minutes!
Does he have a catheter in place?
No way! They put a catheter
in so he could pee?
Enter Daniel Scali.
(slow drum music)
Three hours in, and
he's keeping good form.
Part of the thing
of keeping a plank is having
really strong shoulders
in addition to a strong core.
And the core is not just
your abdominal muscle.
It's your obliques.
It's your posterior
erector spinae muscles.
Five hours, six hours.
- The seven hour mark came.
My body started to turn
on me a little bit.
- I can't even do anything
for seven hours straight
without taking a break,
and my guy's planking.
- I started to actually vomit on myself.
- He vomited while doing it?
Look at this guy! He didn't
even need a catheter!
He vomited while doing it!
- Three, two, one.
- Coming out of it has
gotta be brutal, too.
(record scratches)
Stop the video.
We need to give him a
group round of applause.
That is so hard.
My trainer will be like,
"90 seconds, Mike."
I'm like, "90? C'mon, 60, 75."
This guy, nine plus hours.
- I have the biggest mouth in the world.
- Largest gape?
I've never heard of it
referred to as a gape.
Wow. That is an open mouth.
How many McDonald cheeseburgers
can Isaac fit in his mouth?
Do I wanna know the
answer to that question?
He's wearing a Patriots shirt.
I wonder if he has some
laxity in his TMJ area,
or is just anatomically,
this is a normal variation.
- I am the Guinness World Record holder
for the most cans stuck to a human head.
- What? The most drink cans placed
on the head using air suction.
I'm fascinated.
If a patient came to me and said,
"Cans stick to my head,"
I would be at a loss.
I wouldn't know. Should I refer?
Should I write a case report up?
Like, this is very unique.
- Went to a doctor.
I walked in with a can of peanuts stuck
to the side of my head.
And he goes, "How do you do that?"
I go, "That's what I'm here for.
I want to find out how I do it."
So he did a couple of things
and that's when he told me
he thinks my skin pores suck
in oxygen and makes things stick to me
and that I'm literally, like,
one of four in the world that he knows of.
- What? That is the coolest thing.
I wonder if there's any
medical negatives from this.
- Full can of peanuts. I just...
- Hold on. This has gotta be a prank.
- [Sam] This is real.
- What's the condition?
His body temperature is a
hundred degrees Fahrenheit,
which causes skin pores
to act like suction cups.
Keeton's wounds heal faster,
he gets sick less, and
ages slower than most.
(sighs) Sticky skin syndrome.
Back to the records in just a second,
but first I wanna thank
Dropbox for sponsoring
this part of the video.
My team and I use Dropbox
when making our videos
'cause it's a reliable storage solution
that doesn't share our
private information.
Our footage can't be lost or destroyed
and it's easily accessible
anytime, anywhere.
Dropbox Professional allows
for external collaboration
and creative workflow.
We are regularly storing
and sharing large files,
like the raw clips to this video
that you're watching right now.
And with Dropbox secure backup,
choosing them was a no-brainer.
They even allow access to
files on multiple devices,
like how I'm viewing
these world record videos
on Dropbox on my computer,
while Sam follows along
with me through Dropbox
on his phone.
It allows us to focus on productivity
without the clutter and distraction
of searching for content and switching
between too many things.
Their premium features
and advanced sharing tools
streamline our entire workflow
and help us impress our partners
when we send them videos to review.
It's essential to our
entire production process.
Visit dropbox.com/doctormike
and start a free trial of
Dropbox Professional now.
Huge thanks to Dropbox again
for sponsoring this part of the video.
Let's get back to the world records.
Longest duration restraining
four motorcycles.
No! This looks like a
medieval torture device.
(heavy rock music)
Just imagine if this goes wrong
and the gentleman loses an arm.
Don't do this at home.
Don't do this at work.
There is no reason to do this!
Can you imagine that
guy walking into a bar?
"Hey babe, what's up?
You know what I did last night?
I tied up motorcycles to all of my limbs
and let them pulled me apart
and they couldn't do it for 24 seconds.
How you doing?"
(screen beeps)
I feel like you could literally
make anything a record
if you really wanted to be a record.
Yo, tell them I did this eight time.
(people laughing)
No one knows what's the record.
Look at that.
I just set the record.
Most consecutive muscle ups.
Yo. Oh man, muscle ups are so hard.
Tricep, lat, bicep strength,
forearm strength, grip,
so much is happening.
And good form, too. Excellent form.
Wow. 26 is the record.
I feel like I've seen some dudes
in central park that
could probably beat this.
There's also some
gymnasts that I feel like
that might be able to beat that.
Longest duration full
body contact with ice.
That already sounds painful.
The real danger with ice when it
is making full body contact,
is that it could actually burn your skin.
That's why when I tell you put some ice
on your injured shoulder or knee,
I always say put something in between
because I don't want
you to burn your skin.
You could literally develop frostbite.
This person's just chilling.
He beat the previous record
of 2 hours 35 minutes.
How much further can he go?
His heart rate's probably so low.
The reason you see him shivering there
is he's trying to warm up.
Wow, 3 hours 28 seconds.
I love that it's
sponsored by these brands.
Like, who's doing that?
Whoa. His ear temperature's
33. That's really low.
So he's hypothermic.
- I'm Cathie Jung, and I am currently
in the Guinness book
for the smallest waist
on a living person.
- This is very not
recommended and unhealthy.
A few things happen when you
wear a waist trainer like that.
One, you start actually
weakening your core muscles
because you're not allowing
them to expand properly
and function properly.
Second, you're also
cramming your intestines
from properly performing peristalsis,
which is that movement of
food throughout your body.
Then you're also affecting
your breathing because
in order to breathe, your
ribs need to expand properly
and your diaphragm needs to lower.
That's why we talk about belly breathing.
So when you shallow breathe like that,
you actually lose a part of your lungs
through a condition known as atelectasis.
But also it's short-lived.
If you stop wearing the corsets,
it'll return back to normal.
And thank God for that.
The human body wants to
return back to normal.
- Sultan Kosen, 8'1", 246
and a half centimeters.
Confirmed as the Guinness World Record's
world's tallest man.
- He has a pituitary tumor secreting
a hormone called growth hormone.
- The pituitary gland
is sometimes known as the master gland,
'cause it secretes some of
the most important hormones
that actually end up regulating,
sometimes, other hormones.
Sometimes you can have a tumor
grow in the pituitary gland,
which is actually not cancerous,
but it is one that produces
more of a certain hormone.
Also melanocytes, which secrete melanin,
the cells that give your skin pigment,
actually are controlled by
melanocyte stimulating hormone,
which is also found in
your pituitary gland.
- How tall are you?
- 24 inch.
- 24 inches. Two feet.
- [Interviewer] How was it to appear
in "American Horror Story"?
(woman speaking foreign language)
- Oh, that's cool.
(woman continues speaking
foreign language)
That's a great way to
turn something unique
that's happened to you
into a strength, into an asset.
A good example of
post-traumatic growth there.
Okay. What are we about to do?
Most consecutive stairs climbed
while balancing a person on the head.
Who set this record in the first place?
Wow. I have trouble doing a handstand.
These guys are headstanding up steps.
Well deserved. And look
at the beautiful location.
This should be a double award.
Most beautiful backdrop
for consecutive stairs climbed
with a person on the head.
I wonder how long they practice for.
Oh my God, can you
imagine if they mess up?
You fall down all those steps. Worst fear.
(suspenseful classical music)
What is this a contest for?
Albert Einstein lookalikes? Hah.
(man speaking foreign language)
Oh, are these hyper smellers?
It's, like, hyperosmia or something.
(man speaking foreign language)
- It's really true, though.
There are some people who are
considered super-smellers.
In fact, we did a whole
special episode tailored
to an individual who was a super-smeller
and can actually smell
Parkinson's on certain patients,
including her own husband.
So remember, the sense of
smell is a chemical receptor.
It's when a chemical binds
to the olfactory epithelium
within your nose,
and it starts sending
nerve signals to your brain
in order for you to understand
what that chemical is.
The longest nose on a living
person belongs to this person.
Just because his nose is long doesn't mean
that's why he has such
a great sense of smell.
Remember, this is a neurological
phenomenon that's happening
but I will say you can have
disturbances in your anatomy.
The olfactory cleft can be bigger
or smaller in some people
or blocked off in others,
where it could decide whether
or not you have a strong sense of smell.
The olfactory region in dogs in comparison
to humans is so much better.
Like 40,000 times better.
Click here for a doctor
day in the life vlog.
I literally go see a dermatologist
to get my eye injected.
That's right. I know it
doesn't make a lot of sense,
so click here to watch it.
Cool day. Day in the life
of a doctor. Click here.
As always, stay happy and healthy,
but most importantly, click here.
(upbeat music)